viele kranke Kinder verzweifelte Eltern
frustrierte Ärzte in den Kinderkliniken
geht zur Zeit nichts mehr ein
atemwegsvirus sorgt für viele Patienten
und zeigt einmal mehr auf das System ist
überlastet zu wenig Personal zu wenig
Geld zu wenig Zeit das soll sich ändern
Medizin geht in Zukunft vor Ökonomie das
verspricht Bundesgesundheitsminister
Lauterbach heute hat er die Ergebnisse
der Regierungskommission zur
krankenhausreform vorgestellt
Kinderkliniken am Limit helfen
Lauterbach Reformpläne unser Thema in
der phönix-runde
Phoenix Runde
somit im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes eine
osmaner Sicht Revolution im
krankenhaussekt ein Revolution die wir
unbedingt benötigen und auch etwas was
dazu beitragen wird dass die
Personalprobleme in den Krankenhäusern
besser werden und zwar deshalb derzeit
verlassen viele Pflegekräfte aber auch
viele Ärztinnen und Ärzte die verlassen
die Krankenhäuser weil sie diesen
ökonomischen Druck nicht ertragen wollen
schönen guten Abend aus Berlin ja reden
wir über die Revolution im
Gesundheitswesen und auch die aktuelle
Lage vor allem bei kranken Kindern und
zwar mit diesen Gästen ich begrüße Jakob
Maske erst Sprecher des Bundesverbandes
der Kinder und jugendärzte und Facharzt
für Kinder und Jugendmedizin und hat
eine Praxis in Berlin
und ebenfalls Fachärztin für Kinder und
Jugend bei Medizin Entschuldigung ist
Nese hat baradari und zurzeit ist sie
aber Bundestagsabgeordnete der SPD und
natürlich Mitglied im
Gesundheitsausschuss Ihnen herzlich
willkommen sie sind uns zugeschaltet und
herzlich willkommen Reinhard Busse er
ist Professor für Management im
Gesundheitswesen an der Technischen
Universität Berlin und er war Mitglied
der Regierungskommission für eine
moderne und bedarfsgerechte
Krankenhausversorgung so heißt das und
herzlich willkommen Kaya klapsa
Redakteurin für Innenpolitik der Zeitung
die Welt mit dem Schwerpunkt
Gesundheitspolitik
Herr Maske würden hört viele Geschichten
über die Situation im Moment in den
Kinderkliniken was erleben Sie in Ihrer
Praxis wenn sie Kinder einweisen wollen
in eine Klinik ja das ist im Moment eine
echte Schwierigkeit und das ist auch
genau die Schwierigkeit die wir in
dieser infektwelle die wir ja eigentlich
gewohnt sind haben wir sehen sehr sehr
kranke Kinder meistens unter einem Jahr
alt und wir haben die Problematik dass
wir diese Kinder nicht zeitnah in
Kliniken unterbringen können also
Beispiel in Berlin wir haben acht
Kinderkliniken wir müssen teilweise bei
sechs Kinderkliniken anrufen und kriegen
dann erst ein Bett so war die Situation
letzte Woche gestern noch gab es gar
kein Bett mehr in den Berliner
Kinderkliniken die Kinder konnten also
nicht in Berlin aufgenommen werden sie
wurden über lange Strecken verlegt nach
Frankfurt oder nach Cottbus nach Potsdam
aber auch diese Kliniken haben
inzwischen angemeldet dass sie keinen
Platz mehr für Kinder haben kann man
jetzt sagen das ist eine so
außergewöhnliche Situation darauf kann
man sich so nicht vorbereiten man kann
nicht aber für alle für eine solche
Situation komplett alles vorhalten
also nicht sagen sondern wir sehen diese
infektwelle jedes Jahr und wir sehen Sie
unter Umständen etwas früher aber nicht
stärker wir haben also Infekte in
gleicher Form jedes Jahr und wir sehen
einfach ein Ergebnis von schlechter
Gesundheitspolitik von eingesparten
Betten über die Jahre und von
überlasteten Pferd und Personal was
immer mehr abgebaut wird und in dieser
Situation wo es eben jetzt mal etwas
mehr Infekte gibt bricht dieses System
regelrecht zu rasam wir sehen das
schwerstkranke Kinder die
Sauerstoffbedarf haben die teilweise
beatmet werden über hunderte von
Kilometern verlegt werden in andere
Kliniken das ist sicherlich etwas was
der Gesundheit dieser Kinder und
Jugendlichen nicht zuträglich ist im
Gegenteil er wusste wenn wir das Hören
ist das ein Punkt wo man sagt das war
einer der Gründe die Situation wie es im
Moment ist und wie man wie man auch
befürchtet hat dass er sich so
entwickelt dass im Mai gesagt wurde so
jetzt müssen wir mal was grundsätzlich
ändern und da hat sich ja diese
Reformkommission zum ersten Mal
getroffen
vielfältige Probleme im Krankenhaus
Wesen und die Regierungskommission ist
ja einberufen worden auf Grundlage des
Koalitionsvertrages also die Idee ist ja
schon vor einem Jahr
geschaffen worden und es ist nicht die
die die Überlastung der Kinderkliniken
die jetzt dafür ausschlaggebend war
sondern wir haben ja die verschiedenen
Faktoren wir haben halt eine sehr
zersplitterte krankenhaushause aus
Landschaft und wir haben jetzt so
gleichzeitig sozusagen
Fehlbedarf das ist das zu viele
Patienten gibt in manchen Stellen und es
gibt Krankenhäuser da ist es in anderen
Abteilungen jetzt rede nicht über
Kindermedizin da ist er ist sehr sehr
wenig los und wir müssen das besser
verteilen die Krankenhäuser leiden auch
unter
ihren finanziellen Nöten die
paradoxerweise dadurch ausgelöst sind
dass zurzeit zu wenig Patienten kommen
alle Krankenhäuser Leben auf der Basis
dass sie in den letzten 15 20 Jahren die
Zahl ihrer Patienten immer erhöht haben
erhöht haben erhöht haben durch die
corona-krise sind Patienten weggebrochen
das führt zu Finanzproblemen das führt
zu Frust beim beim Personal und das
kommt jetzt alles zusammen und deswegen
brauchen wir wirklich einen großen Wurf
einen großen Wurf der Minister sprach
von der Revolution ja heute Frau
baradari jetzt hört man dass sich vieles
ändern soll das hilft aber doch im
Moment dann nicht gibt es irgendwas wo
man sagen kann wie können wir diese
dramatische Situation die Maske eben
besprochen wie kann man das eigentlichen
in solchen besonderen Situationen
hin wäre ja etwas hinterher muss man
sagen ich bin aber froh dass wir
zusammen meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen
aus der Ampelkoalition schon auch
zusammen mit dem Gesundheitsminister
vereinbaren konnten dass die Pädiatrie
wirklich ein speziellen Platz bekommen
soll und daher bin ich froh dass
jährlich ich habe 2023 für die Pädiatrie
300 Millionen Euro zur Verfügung
gestellt werden das ist ein erster
Schritt die Pädiatrie braucht in der Tat
noch mehr
finanzielle Unterstützung personelle
Unterstützung die sicherlich auch vom
Gesetzgeber dementsprechend flankiert
werden müsste wir brauchen einen
Bürokratie abbauen denn viele Ärztinnen
und Ärzte sind mit Gutachten beschäftigt
oder artistierungen daneben brauchen wir
wirklich auch jetzt eine Reform und auch
eine Revolution was die Digitalisierung
angeht damit auch hier
Arbeitsprozesse verstanden werden können
denn aufgrund des demografischen Wandels
werden wir auch in Zukunft nicht so
viele Pflegekräfte und medizinische
Kräfte haben das wird Jahre dauern oder
halt sind wir gefordert damit
schnellstmöglich jetzt anfangen
hinterher linken hinterher und die Pläne
dauern auch bisschen umgesetzt sind doch
einige Jahre trotzdem am letzten Freitag
gab es das Krankenhaus Pflege
entlastungsgesetz unter anderem wurden
eben diese 300 Millionen da beschlossen
für Kinderkliniken Frau Klopfer einmal
letzten Freitag im Bundestag das heute
die Pressekonferenz die Vorstellung der
Pläne der Regierungskommission wie
beurteilen Sie die die Tatkraft der
Regierung im Sinne der
Gesundheitspolitik also man muss sagen
die langfristigen Maßnahmen die jetzt
angestrebt werden da hatte Lauterbach
schon früh ein Auge drauf also ich
glaube man kann ihm nicht vorwerfen dass
er die Kliniken hat außer Acht gelassen
man weiß ja wie Herr Buster zittert die
Kommission hat sie schon im Mai
getroffen da wurde schon lange dran
gearbeitet was man ihm glaube ich aber
schon vorwerfen kann ist die Frage der
kurzfristigen Maßnahmen er hat heute in
einem Interview gesagt ihres Paul Welle
war so mit der hatte so niemand
gerechnet und ich glaube genau also
diese diese massenhaften Erkrankungen
jetzt der Kinder mit diesem Virus da
hätte man nicht mitgerechnet und wie wir
wissen von vielen Ärzten wurde schon in
den letzten Wochen zum Teil Monaten
gewarnt dass wir auf Engpässe
zulaufen das ist ja auch in den
vergangenen Jahren genau dieses Virus
gegeben hat also ich dann hinzustellen
und zu sagen dass damit haben wir so
nicht gerechnet finde ich schwierig und
man hätte diese kurzfristigen Maßnahmen
dies ja jetzt gibt also z.B dass man
personalverlagert von anderen Station
auf die Kinderstation ich weiß das hilft
nur bedingt wenn nicht jeder ist dafür
qualifiziert aber zum Teil kann das
schon helfen das hätte man z.B auch
schon vor 6 Wochen beschließen können
natürlich das ist eine Maßnahme die
eigentlich von medizinischer Unkenntnis
nur so strotzt ich kenne keinen einzigen
Arzt der sich traut sozusagen wirklich
intensivpflichtig kranke Kinder und
irgendwie geht's ja hier dann auch auf
der Intensivstation zu betreuen also ich
selber würde mir auch trotz langjähriger
krankenhausserfahrung und auch intensiv
Erfahrung überhaupt nicht mehr zutrauen
jetzt nach mehreren Jahren Praxis ein
Kind zu beatmen zum Beispiel also hier
Ärzte völlig fachfremd für die Betreuung
von Kindern einzusetzen ist also
völliger Unsinn in meinen Augen oder in
unseren Augen des Berufsverbandes kinder
sind keine kleinen Erwachsenen hier
braucht es anderen Mittel um akut für
diese Kinder zu sorgen und das gleiche
trifft dafür die Pflege zu welche
erwachsenenpflegekraft möchte denn auf
die Neonatologie gehen auf die
Neugeborenen Station und Frühgeborenes
mit 500 Gramm versorgen wer kann das
denn gar keiner kann das sein jetzt
konkret also wenn wir reden gleich noch
natürlich ausführlich über ihre
formpläne die lange längerfristig wirken
sondern aber gibt es was wo sie sagen
das müsste jetzt passieren damit wir
jetzt diesen Notstand sind ich glaube
diese ganz akuten Sachen das ist einfach
der der Zug abgefahren und wir müssen
mit den Mitteln arbeiten die wir haben
also höchstens hat er Lauterbach auch
gesagt gerade das ist auch richtig was
er gesagt hat wir müssen die
Pflegerinnen und Pfleger wir müssen die
Ärztinnen und Ärzte dort behalten wo sie
sind sie dürfen nicht abwandern und das
können wir nur wenn indem wir sie
wertschätzen das heißt indem wir sie
durch Anreize halten und das ist im
Moment nicht der Fall und ich muss noch
mal auch widersprechen also auch die
langfristigen Sachen hat Herr Lauterbach
leider nicht ordentlich bedacht weil er
nur an die Kliniken denkt er denken
nicht an die ambulante Medizin ähm das
tut er nicht er lässt letztendlich die
ambulante Medizin gegen die Wand fahren
es werden immer mehr Praxen geschlossen
es gibt keine Nachfolger und auch da
möchte ich noch mal einhalten bei Frau
bei der dari ähm wir brauchen auch eine
Kinderkrankenpflege die ordentlich
ausgebildet wird ne das haben wir nicht
mehr wir haben eine generalistische
Ausbildung und bei den Pflegekräften
genau und keine spezielle
Kinderkrankenpflege mehr und diese wird
auch spezialisiert nirgendwo in
Deutschland ausgeht außer in Hamburg in
einem kleinen Stadtstaat okay er wusste
was wenn man das jetzt so hört dann ist
deine Menge ist es auch einfach viel
Frust beim beim Personal das hat ja
Lauterbach hier auch so dass viele Leute
nicht mehr gehen was könnte sich denn
jetzt ändern durch ihre Reformvorschläge
wenn der Minister sagt Ökonomie soll
nicht mehr vor Medizin gehen es soll
umgekehrt sein naja was ich ändern wird
und das soll ja auch beim Personal
ankommen das natürlich alle sowohl Ärzte
ich bin ja selber Arzt
Pflegepersonal wenn wir als wir studiert
haben die Ausbildung gewählt haben dann
hat man ja den Wunsch der Bevölkerung zu
helfen also manchmal das ist ja
sozusagen die sind die sind alle
intrinsisch motiviert und es geht dann
zum Teil während der Berufstätigkeit
verloren weil halt bei den Ärzten man
mitkriegt es werden Operationen
durchgeführt die halt überwiegen gemacht
werden weil sie Geld bringen man könnte
die Patienten auch konservativ behandeln
also erstmal abwarten und gucken ob das
nicht wirkt also es wird ja wir haben
einerseits diese Überaktivität und dass
das merkt dass das merken die
Beschäftigten dass der Patienten
behandelt werden wegen der finanziell
keine Interessen der der Krankenhäuser
und sie würden lieber anders wieder an
das Vorgehen und insbesondere sind ja
immer mehr Krankenhäuser auf lukrative
Dinge aufgesprungen machen Operation
Wirbelsäulenoperation obwohl sie nicht
indiziert sind und eigentlich die
kleinen Krankenhäusern machen werden
operiert deswegen gar nicht unbedingt
nötig ist genau ganz wichtig dass man
dann sagt okay Krankenhäuser kriegen und
das ist ja jetzt ihre Form werden klar
Stufen zugeordnet und die Stufen haben
die klare Aufgabe wir wir unterscheiden
ja meistens nicht die Krankenhäuser in
Deutschland in Dorf Krankenhaus anfängt
Herz Herz transportiert zu dürfen die
das und nachdem Reform dürfen sie das
nicht mehr dann wäre ganz klar es gibt
so eine untere Stufe eine mittlere Stufe
und eine obere Stufe und die dürfen nur
das machen wozu sie auch qualifiziert
sind was auch im Sinne des Person halten
die Krankenhäuser da spezielle Personal
vor was sie für diese Patienten brauchen
was aber dann vielleicht schwierig ist
für Menschen die auf dem Land leben und
dann immer weit fahren müssen das ist ja
glaube ich
muss man da auch mal die Kirche im Dorf
lassen wir haben 1700 akute
krankenhausstandorte und wir haben wenn
man sich die halbwegs vernünftig
ausgestatteten Krankenhäuser anguckt
also die Intensivmedizin notfallstufe ab
der mittleren Stufe haben dann haben wir
425 wir haben also zurzeit 425 gut
ausgestattete Krankenhäuser und 1300
kleine 1300 kleine Krankenhäuser und wir
sagen der Bevölkerung immer du bist
schnell in so einem kleinen Krankenhaus
aber dann sind sie schnell im kleinen
Krankenhaus da ist kein linksherz
Katheter wenn man Herzinfarkt hat das
keine Schlaganfall Einheit wenn man
Schlaganfall hat also wir gaukeln auch
vor dass die kleinen Krankenhäuser dann
helfen im Notfall besser ist es dann
gleich zu sagen das ist ein Krankenhaus
wurde mit Schlaganfall und Herzinfarkt
hingehen kannst und das ist eins das da
kannst du damit nicht hingehen und das
wird kommen okay ist das richtig dass
man sagt wir brauchen weniger
Krankenhäuser bzw weniger Krankenhäuser
die sozusagen alles können
ich teile die Einstellung von Herr
Professor Busse nur zum Teil gerade wenn
es um Schlaganfall geht oder um
Herzinfarkt wissen wir doch je früher
dort interveniert wird umso besser ist
das out kommt insofern muss man nicht
erst mal sehr sehr schwer verletzt sein
oder auch im Trauma haben ich finde auch
diese Versorgung ist ganz ganz wichtig
daher
braucht das System sicherlich ein Update
das kann ich verstehen aber das darf auf
keinen Fall zu lassen der medizinische
Versorgung der Bevölkerung sein und das
würde es sein noch ein Wort zu meinen
Kollegen Herr Maske also ich bin auch
noch praktisch tätig oder um das zu
sagen die Situation die sie schildern
kennen wir hier auch vom Wort sie haben
Recht leute bitte auch hier oben ist
auch gegenüber dem Gesundheitsminister
was Jahre ja Jahrzehnte lang
kaputt gespart worden ist insbesondere
im Bereich der ambulanten oder
stationären Pädiatrie das können wir und
werden wir nicht innerhalb eines Jahres
aufheben können also da bitte ich auch
mehr Realismus aber natürlich stehen wir
in der Pflicht alles Mögliche zu tun
dass das auf dem Weg gebracht wird und
dass es gebessert wird wie gesagt erste
Schritte haben wir dazu getan aber wenn
man ganz ehrlich ist das wird auch noch
einige Jahre brauchen bis das
implementiert ist was sie
generalistische Ausbildung angeht bin
ich offen gesagt kein Freund davon
gewesen wir werden in eine
Pflegeausbildung und nicht eine
spezielle Kinderkrankenpflege zum
Beispiel
richtig wir werden sehen wie die ersten
ausgebildeten
Pflegefachkräfte wenn ich auf dem Markt
kommen wie sich das darstellt es gibt
diesbezüglich eine Spezialisierung
Vertiefung in der Pädiatrie aber die
kann meiner Meinung nach natürlich nicht
adäquat sein zu früher wo speziell was
Kinder angeht klar
Kinderkrankenpflege beigebracht worden
ist
sie sagten gerade man müsste her umgehen
mit dem Minister Lauterbach sich genauso
aber dann würde ich auch führerweise
gerne hinzufügen dass er ja bei der
Entwicklung des fallfahrscheinsystems
also dieses Vergütungssystem was er
gerade auch zu diesen vielen schlimmen
Konsequenzen führt dass er das ja auch
mit entwickelt hat vor 20 Jahren an
entscheidender Stelle und er selbst sagt
auch bei jeder Gelegenheit dass er die
Gesundheitspolitik obwohl ja gar nicht
in einer hochrangigen Funktion war aber
er sagt immer gerne hätte die
gesundheitsbedingt der letzten 20 Jahre
maßgeblich mitgeprägt das ist dass das
was er immer wieder erzählt und da finde
ich schon erstaunlich dass er zwar jetzt
sehr selbstkritisch auch umgeht mit mit
sich auch mit seinen Kollegen und schon
sagt dass es dem wie bis jetzt haben das
funktioniert nicht mehr aber die
Einsicht kommt dann doch etwas später
finde ich wir haben wie ist das mit den
Fall pauschalen wie viel bekommen Sie
wenn Sie ja bei einer
Vorsorgeuntersuchung für ein Kind oder
so wie kann man das eigentlich mal
umrechnen was das bedeutet in der Praxis
also zunächst muss ich erstmal dieses
Bild vom Arzt der aus Spaß und Profit
operiert und Dinge macht noch mal so ein
bisschen zurücknehmen das mag
Einzelfälle geben aber es ist nicht die
Regel und wir haben auch jetzt schon
Mindestgrenzen für bestimmte Dinge die
Krankenhäuser einhalten müssen um eben
diese Art von Patienten zu behandeln und
insofern würde ich das ganz stark
natürlich auch zurücknehmen für die
Kinder und jugendärzte und die Kinder
und Jugendmedizin da findet sowas soweit
ich weiß nicht statt da mag es
Einzelfälle geben aber kein Kind wird
irgendwie behandelt um eben Profit zu
machen ja das ist tatsächlich eher eine
Rarität machen Einzelfällen vorkommen
aber so ist nicht die Realität in
unseren Kliniken
die Fallpauschale ist ja eher ein
Begriff aus der stationären Medizin aber
ich gucke gerne noch mal zurück auf die
ambulante Medizin die ja auch kaputt
gespart wird durch auch eine Politik die
hat lauter Macht die er
verunsichert ist und nicht verlässlich
ist
wir kriegen unser Bezahlsystem ist
sowieso ganz schwierig zu erklären das
kann man gar nicht in drei Sätzen machen
wir kriegen eine Pauschale für einen
Patienten wenn er einmal im Quartal
kommt ne das ist ein bestimmter Betrag
den wir aber auch bekommen wenn dieser
gleiche Patient 15 Mal kommt ja und hier
sehe ich genau ein Problem der
Ökonomisierung der Medizin der Herr
Lauterbach doch auch vorantreibt
vielleicht nicht der stationären Medizin
aber doch der ambulanten Medizin der
denn erfordert Investoren
geleitete medizinische
Versorgungszentren Investoren sind
Menschen die Geld verdienen wollen die
nicht einfach Geld irgendwo reinstecken
und gucken wie es versammelt sondern sie
wollen Geld verdienen und Investoren
sorgen dafür dass die Medizin sich lohnt
ja und Kinder und Jugendmedizin lohnt
sich nicht zumindest nicht pikulär aber
sie lohnt sich sehr wohl für die weitere
Vorsorge wir haben eine
Daseinsvorsorge die wir machen müssen
heute bei der was die Kinder was die
klin betrifft ja noch mal sehr stark dem
wurde gegengesprochen also wie
funktioniert es denn dann Herr wusste
also wie wirkt sich wie wirklich der
Kostendruck auf die Krankenhäuser aus
und was soll sich dann ändern wenn es
dann in Zukunft nicht mehr diese
pauschalen geben sollen also die
Fallpauschalen bleiben ja erhalten und
die Fallpauschalen muss man sich ja
sicher so vorstellen sind erstmal
Klassifikationssystem also die derzeit
ungefähr 16 17 Millionen Patienten
natürlich sind das alles Individuen die
werden in einer endliche Anzahl von
Gruppen einsortiert das sind so 1300
Gruppen diese Gruppen sind derzeit
werden dafür benutzt um die Leistung der
Krankenhäuser zu bezahlen also in jeder
der für jede dieser 1300 Gruppen gibt es
einen Preis und die Krankenhäuser
kriegen jeweils diesen Preis für alle
Patienten innerhalb von einer Gruppe so
damit hat man aber man wenn man
Fixkosten hat also wenn sie Geräte haben
dann ist natürlich profitabla sie haben
in einem Krankenhaus mehr
solcher Fälle weil sie die Fixkosten
besser verteilen können
das schafft schon Druck auch auf
Patientenzahlen hin wir wollen das
ändern in den in dem die die Fall also
die Gruppen bleiben erhalten die
patientenwahl werden weiterhin in eine
Gruppe einsortiert aber es gibt weniger
Geld für jeden für jeder die dieser
Gruppe also das wird reduziert und das
rausgenommene Geld wird anders verteilt
nämlich auf die Krankenhäuser die
überhaupt Patienten dieser Gruppe noch
behandeln dürfen das heißt die kriegen
mehr Geld vorab und wissen das kann
sozusagen mit dem gespart mit dem Meer
an Geld was ist kann es an selber
umgehen
das Geld ja nur wenn Patienten kommen
und deswegen sind ja auch muss man sich
vorstellen die Krankenhäuser zur Zeit so
finanziell Schwierigkeiten weil wir seit
Corona 14% weniger Patienten haben die
fehlen auch in der Kasse so und jetzt
sagen wir wir müssen umsortieren statt
100 € im nachher rein kriegt man schon
40 € vor ab um damit schon zu planen zu
die Geräte zu finanzieren Personal zu
haben selbst wenn die Kinderklinik
sozusagen mal lehrere Tage hat im Sommer
dann ist es nicht gleich so dass das
Krankenhaus finanziell leiden muss und
auf die Idee kommt Betten abzubauen also
es gibt eine gewisse Grundpauschale als
vorhaltefinanzierung und die
verkleinerten Fallpauschalen
Puffern dann sozusagen nur die nur nur
die variablen Kosten ab natürlich ist
ein Krankenhaus teurer wenn Patienten da
sind als wenn sie leer ist das wird
durch die Fallpauschalen
geregel genau ist denn dann die
Revolution Herr Busse die Revolution ist
und das muss ich jetzt leider hier
widersprechen das mit der das wir werden
Gaul mehr Bevölkerung zur Zeit vor dass
die Krankenhäuser alle gleich gut sind
die sind nicht gleich gut es behandeln
über 1000 Krankenhäuser Patienten mit
Herzinfarkt von den haben knapp über 500
haben links Herzkatheter wir haben 500
Krankenhäuser in Deutschland das sagt
man der Bevölkerung da wirst du gut
versorgt die haben keinen links
Herzkatheter die dürfen das in Zukunft
nicht wir haben nicht mehr machen das
heißt die Patienten die brauche ich doch
aber woanders also dann was heißt denn
das für die Patienten dass ich mit das
noch weniger Anlaufstelle gibt noch
weniger also wir nehmen ja kein
Herzkatheter Weg die Patienten können
nicht mehr dahin gehen wo sie bisher
schlecht versorgt worden sind weil es
kein linksherzkatheter gab wir bauen ja
nicht links Herzkatheter ab wir bauen
keine Kinder und Jugendmedizin ab
sondern wir sagen Klara da sind
Krankenhäuser die verfügen über das
richtige Personal die richtige
Ausstattung da musst du hingehen es
macht nicht mehr jeder
alles sondern wir sagen wir ordnen die
Krankenhäuser klarer ein und die die den
Versorgungsauftrag dann haben für die
jeweiligen Leistungsgruppen die kriegen
das Geld vorab um die
vorhaltefinanzierung schon mal sicher zu
haben
ich bin tatsächlich auch noch auf der
Suche nach der Revolution Lauterbach
sagt ja seit Wochen seit Monaten schon
er wolle die Fallpauschalen überwinden
ein Ende der scheinen sie sagen gerade
sind Mitglied der Kommission auch andere
Kommissionsmitglieder haben heute gesagt
die bleiben sie werden nur ein bisschen
abgesenkt und es kommen eben diese
vorhaltefinanzierung dazu also dass man
nicht nur vergütet wird wenn man auch
ganz viel behandelt sondern eben auch
nur dafür dass man da ist zum Beispiel
Geburtsklinik und so weiter und das ist
eben keine Überwindung der der Fall
wahrscheinlich und auch keine keine
große Revolution und ich glaube da wird
es noch viel Enttäuschung geben bei
denjenigen die sich dabei Lauterbach auf
dieses Wort verlassen haben in der
letzten Wochen Monaten ich persönlich
bin es richtig dass man die Fall
wahrscheinlich komplett zur Seite legt
weil ich glaube ein bisschen
Ökonomisierung ist schon sinnvoll ich
glaube man muss auch irgendwie
honorieren wenn dann auf der sich
versorgt wird aber er hat irgendwas
anderes angekündigt und muss jetzt so
ein bisschen zurückholen und sagen na ja
so ist es dann doch nicht geworden
die haben zwei Bedeutungen die haben
dieses Bedeutung als als
Klassifikationssystem und da bleiben sie
völlig erhalten wir in Deutschland haben
in der Vergangenheit es gibt ja in fast
allen Länder so so so so dieses
diagi-system was die anderen Länder
schon weniger gemacht haben als wir dass
sie die Krankenhäuser ausschließlich so
bezahlt haben aber die Klassifikation
ist ganz wichtig und eine
Teilfinanzierung in Norwegen die machen
fifty-fifty
Budget zur Hälfte Lauterbach sagt ich
zitiere ihn durchfallpauschalen steht
die Ökonomie jetzt oft vor der Medizin
gleicher Preis pro Fall bedeutet Menge
und billige Leistung machen gewinnen wie
bei Lidl jetzt ist die Frage was heißt
das für die Patienten und dann Frau
baradari was heißt sonst
also ich denke hier geht es eigentlich
um ein Veränderung des Vergütungssystems
das wäre auch der einen Seite
Masse vor Klasse dem Entgegenkommen
wollen ich denke das intendiert auch
unser Gesundheitsminister und auf der
anderen Seite
ganz spezielle Behandlungen wie zum
Beispiel eine Transplantation oder sehr
spezielle Sachen durchaus dann in
spezialisierten Kliniken erfolgen
sollten ich denke daraufhin geht das
dann gibt es aber auch viele Eingriffe
wie teilweise ambulant stattfinden
können wodurch dann auch eine Einsparung
im Gesundheitssystem intentiert wird
also die gleiche Operation sah mir meine
Leistenoperation die kostet dann im
stationären Bereich das sichtbare
während das auch ambulant gemacht werden
kann es geht ja darum dass es im System
nicht wenig Geld gibt und
Gesundheitssystem sondern wie das
verteilt wie wird effizient damit
umgegangen hierbei möchte ich aber
ausdrücklich die Kinderkliniken
natürlich die ambulante pädiatrische
Person und auch die Geburtshilfe
herausnehmen weil das sind Bereiche da
können und dürfen wir auch kein Rotstift
ansetzen weil das gehört zur
Daseinsvorsorge einfach mit dazu das
haben sie ja auch schon gesagt dass es
ganz wichtig ist dass man da halt eben
bei Kinder und Jugendmedizin auf eben
genau überhaupt nicht die nach dem
ökonomischen Druck arbeiten sollte eine
Sache die ihr lauter war ja auch
angesprochen hat dass diese ökonomischen
Druck bei zu Frust führt beim Personal
und das ist ja immer schwieriger wird
Personal zu gewinnen was und auch
schwieriger wird zum Beispiel dass
Menschen Kinderarzt und Kinderärztin
werden wie empfinden Sie das ist das so
das ist schwierig wird Personal zu
bekommen also das ist auf jeden Fall so
wir haben keinen Nachwuchs in fünf
Jahren ist ein Drittel der Kinder und
jugendarztpraxen geschlossen weil die
Menschen pensioniert werden und wir
haben keinen Nachwuchs wir sagen als
Berufsverband der Kinder- und
jugendärzte schon seit 1995 das werden
mehr Studienplätze brauchen zur Wände
ist die studienplatzanzahl deutlich
reduziert worden ja insgesamt für
Gesamtdeutschland das ist eine
Katastrophe wir haben eben kaum noch
Nachfolger und diese Nachfolger werden
auch alle wahrscheinlich nicht mehr voll
arbeiten wollen sondern sie haben andere
Arbeitsmodelle und dazu kommt noch dass
sie sicherlich nicht in der Praxis als
Unternehmer gehen ja denn auch wir sind
Unternehmer wir müssen wirtschaftlich
arbeiten obwohl heute wieder gesagt
wurde sind viele frustriert in den
Kliniken und die gehen dann lieber in
der Praxis weil sie den denen die das
Schichtsystem in den Kliniken auch nicht
attraktiv finden die lassen sich dann
anstellen zum Beispiel in einem
medizinischen Versorgungszentrum sind
dann angestellt haben keine
Verantwortung aber wenn es ein Investor
na wenn es einen Investor geführt ist
MVZ ist dann ist das eben auf Profit
ausgelegt und dann fallen im Patienten
die Geld kosten ja weil sie häufig
kommen oder weil sie chronisch krank
sind fallen hinten runter die werden
nicht mehr behandelt und das sehen wir
ja auch schon in den Kliniken Patienten
die sich nicht lohnen werden häufiger
sprühen lassen oder werden es gar nicht
aufgenommen wir haben Kliniken die die
teilweise bestimmte
Diagnosen Patienten mit Diagnosen nicht
mehr aufnehmen weil es sich nicht lohnt
und genau dieses System dürfen wir nicht
haben und noch ein ganz kurzer Satz die
Kinder und Jugend mit sie darf sich
nicht sekundär lohnen die lohnt sich von
sich aus und muss einfach bezahlt werden
vielleicht reden wir auch wirklich zu
viel übers Geld hier also wir wir da und
wir müssen an die an die Patienten
denken und dann in das Gute Stichwort
ambulantisierung gehört und auch da
geht's ja nicht primär ums Geld wir
wollen nicht die Patienten ambulant
behandeln primär damit die Krankenkassen
Geld sparen sondern es ist ja wir haben
50 Prozent mehr krankenhausfälle als als
im Schnitt unser Nachbarländer also wir
werden wesentlich intensiver Stadt
stationär behandelt aber haben wir das
weil sich das lohnende können teilweise
ja teilweise weil wir eine andere
Tradition haben teilweise vor allem auch
weil wir so viele Krankenhäuser haben
und ist sozusagen viel mehr in der
Tradition von uns als Ärzten drin ist ob
Patienten stationär zu tun zu zu
behandeln so und das führt dazu dass
unser vorhandenes Pflegepersonal und wir
haben relativ viel nur Finnland hat mehr
Pflegepersonal pro Einwohner als als als
wir haben aber wir haben so viele
Patienten so dass am einzelnen Bett am
belegten Bett kommt relativ wenig
Pflegepersonal an ist ja klar dänemark
hat zwar mir genauso viel Pflegepersonal
wie wir am halb so halb so viele
Patienten dann stehen an jedem Bett
doppelt so viel Pflegepersonal so darum
ändern wenn die Patienten nicht mehr im
Bett liegen sondern ambulant behandelt
werden dann dann liegen weniger
Patienten in den Betten und das in der
Pflegepersonal kann sich um weniger
Patienten kümmern damit mehr Zeit okay
wenn ich jetzt sage Ökonomie ist nicht
mehr so wichtig wie Medizin und wenn ich
jetzt aber aus ökonomischen Gründen
letztendlich die Patienten dann doch
nach Hause schicken geht nicht um
ökonomische Gründe es geht nicht um
ökonomische Gründe es geht darum die
meisten Patienten wollen ja gar nicht
unbedingt im Bett liegen sondern sondern
die wollen auch lieber lieber zu Hause
liegen und die sind dann kein
Krankenhaus kein ausgesetzt und das
Pflegepersonal hat mehr Zeit für die
Patienten die wirklich stationär
behandelt werden müssen und das ist
schon eine Revolution das wird ein
bisschen dauern weil das natürlich auch
eine Revolution im Kopf sein muss bei
den Patienten die nicht immer gleich
stationär gehen wollen was sie mir seit
der Pandemie ja nicht mehr machen wenn
sie damit Hausärzten sprechen früher
hatten die Leute immer gepackten Koffer
wenn Sie Ihren Hausarzt gerufen haben
heute haben sie kein gepacken Körper
mehr da ändert sich schon was aber es
müssen natürlich auch bei den Ärzten
ansetzen dass man sagen ja wir behandeln
die hier die die die ambulant Patienten
Krebspatienten behandeln wir viermal
Station länger im im Schnitt in unseren
zweimal nee jede jeder kommt vier Mal
als patientstationär jeder Krebspatient
im Nachbarländern zweimal weil die
machen viel mehr der Chemotherapie auf
ambulanter Basis wir können da wirklich
die Medizin verändern ich finde es
interessant dass sie gerade eben
Dänemark als Positivbeispiel genannt
haben ihr Kollege
nie das Intensivmediziner auch Mitglied
der Kommission hat heute erst in der
Pressekonferenz berichtet dass Dänemark
eben ja die Strategie gefahren ist
wenige große Krankenhäuser und dafür
eben die kleineren schließen und jetzt
wie er erzählte anfängt wieder kleinere
aufzubauen
die heißen Krankenhäuser aber die haben
null Betten 0 Betten da liegt an
Versorgung für ältere wenig Wohnmobile
Menschen und jetzt müssen die die
geschlossen worden sind wieder aufgebaut
werden also bin ich mal ein bisschen
schwierig mit mit solchen Vergleichen
dann was ich immer noch zum Personal
gern sagen würde was was fehlt das
stimmt natürlich dass es mehr
Studienplätze braucht mehr Ausbildung
und so weiter das sind ja so die großen
Dinge aber was ich auch noch mal gerne
sagen würde es ist ja vor allem auch die
Personal in den letzten zwei Jahren
abgewandert während der Pandemie und
natürlich es hat Herr Spahn früher mal
gesagt kann man Pflegekräfte nicht
backen und man kann das Politiker dann
nur begrenzt was tun aber ich finde es
gab auch einige Maßnahmen die das
verschärft haben also zum Beispiel die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht die
jetzt zum Glück Ende des Jahres ausläuft
ja zu wahnsinnig viel Frust geführt bei
vielen Pflegekräften oder auch der
Pflege Bonus der bei jedem Mal als
ausgestattet wurde
ja zu sehr viel ärgert hat weil es sehr
wirklich ausgestattet worden ist es gibt
gerade eine Petition von den Vivantes
Kliniken in Berlin da ganz viele
Pflegende sagen wir haben den gar nicht
bekommen Legende die in Notaufnahme
arbeiten in Rettungsstellen die jetzt an
Herr Lauterbach eine Petition
geschrieben haben also es gab auch
Maßnahmen wieder pflegebonus die
Impfpflicht und so weiter die das auch
verstärkt haben dass eine Pflegekraft
wie zum Beispiel überlegt soll ich
bleiben soll ich gehen dann sich
vielleicht doch dazu entschieden hat zu
gehen
nochmal fragen zu dieser Sache dass wir
zu viel stationär machen dass man mehr
ambulant machen könnte dann könnte man
ja auch sagen vielleicht dann auch noch
mehr in den Praxen wie finden sie das
also ich glaube die Kinder und
Jugendmedizin ist das beste Beispiel
dafür dass wir eigentlich fast nur noch
ambulant behandeln ja wir schicken
wirklich nur noch schwerstkranke Kinder
und Jugendliche in die Klinik das sehen
wir auch gerade jetzt wieder wir
schicken dann nur die schwerkranken hin
und trotzdem implodiert im Moment das
System
macht zum Beispiel dann wenn die Leute
weniger über Nacht da bleiben müssen
dann sparen wir Personal und das wäre
ein guter Ansatz damit das Personal Zeit
hat für andere Sachen gut das haben wir
glaube ich in der Kinder und
Jugendmedizin schon ganz gut erreicht da
kann man immer noch Verbesserungen
hervorrufen sicherlich über gar kein
Problem aber da sind wir schon sehr weit
in der Kinder und Jugendmedizin aber ich
würde auch gerne mal auf den Pflege
eingehen ja das ist ja ein eine Sache
die den stationären arbeitenden gezahlt
wurde aber unsere medizinischen
Fachangestellten die 85 bis 90 Prozent
der corona-kranken versorgt haben haben
davon nichts gesehen nichts bekommen
auch am Telefon ja und die müssen sich
im Moment beschimpfen lassen und da
besteht die Gefahr dass diese Kollegen
einfach dann tatsächlich auch sagen nee
das lasse ich mir nicht mehr bieten ja
also da muss man sicherlich
kann man noch machen oder was ist jetzt
nur noch geplant damit man sagt dass
diese Berufe Pflege und Ärzte Ärztin
dass das weiter attraktiv bleibt damit
wir diesen Personalmangel der hier
herrscht irgendwie dass wir dann den
decken können
Bedarf ich denke wichtig ist dass man
auch den mfas Wertschätzung
entgegenbringt und dass sie natürlich
auch ein Anrecht haben genauso gut
tariflich bezahlt zu werden und auch von
Boni profitieren das sind nämlich
passiert hergestellt ne richtig genau
angekündigen und Kollegen die das machen
konnten haben das selber gemacht oder
auch dieses Jahr da besteht ja die
Möglichkeit dass auch als Arbeitgeber
Arbeitgeberin 3.500 Euro Steuerfreiheit
als Inflationsausgleich bezahlt werden
kann aber irgendwie mein Kollege schon
gerade sagte
die
gewinnmar sind bei Kinder und
jugendärzten nicht groß und trotzdem
machen es sehr viele Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wo ich Respekt davor habe aber
das ist eine Ungleichbehandlung und
sowohl die vielen corona-patienten als
auch die vielen Corona Impfung diesen
vorigen stationär gemacht worden
in der ambulanten Versorgung und da ist
eine Ungleichbehandlung und aber es ist
so wir leben in einer Demokratie ich
lege schon allen auf dem Ohr nämlich
sage das finde ich nicht gerecht ich
hoffe dass dich da noch mehr Mitstreiter
finden und ich hoffe dass sich das zum
bessere noch wendet Herr Busse wann
rechnen Sie damit dass ich das was jetzt
angekündigt wird und auch das
entlastungsgesetz das letzten Freitag im
Bundestag oder dass das Wirkung zeigt
naja es werden also jetzt beschlossenen
Maßnahmen die treten ja sehr schnell in
Kraft zu zu beginnen nächsten Jahres und
wir werden sehen da gibt es ja auch noch
Widerstände gegen so wie das mehr mehr
tagesbehandlung wir werden sehen es wird
Krankenhäuser geben die werden da sehr
sehr schnell einen einführen dann wird
man auch ein bisschen beobachten müssen
wie die Patienten darauf reagieren ich
glaube die Patienten werden darauf sehr
sehr positiv reagiert das wird ein Druck
ausüben wenn dann erste große
Krankenhäuser da da hingehen und dann
wird es schon zu Veränderung kommen das
was heute bekannt gegeben werden muss
muss ja noch in einen ersten in einen
Gesetzesentwurf gegossen werden aber die
die Probleme sind schon so groß würde
ich sagen und das und und diejenigen die
darauf setzen dass wir das mit mehr Geld
lösen können das mehr Geld alleine würde
mich gar nichts bringen aus dem Hammer
wenig Geld wir müssen wirklich eine
Strukturen ran das wird Widerstände
hervorrufen aber ich denke schon es wird
aus diesem Vorschlag den wir heute als
Kommission auf dem Tisch gelegt haben
und den den der Minister vorgestellt hat
wird schonenden Gesetz werden wir haben
ja dann in dem Vorschlag noch einen
Übergangsfrist vorgesehen die aber
natürlich auch relativ zügig in Kraft
treten soll damit alle schon wissen wo
die Reise hingeht und es wird dann von
ja von Jahr zu Jahr werden sich die
Dinge verändern was denken Sie Herr
Maske ich denke dass Herr Lauterbach im
Moment die ambulante Medizin komplett
gegen die Wand fährt und das auch
wirklich alles dafür tut und auf der
anderen Seite versucht er mehr Leistung
in die Ambulanz zu tragen das passt in
meinen Augen überhaupt nicht zusammen
und es wird auch nicht so sein dass
Krankenhäuser auch kleine Krankenhäuser
solche Leistungen ambulant erbringen
können wir arbeiten auch als
niedergelassene Kinder und jugendärzte
in Ambulanzen wir sehen wie schlecht sie
organisiert sind diese diese Art der
Organisation da würden wir gar keine
Patienten schaffen bei uns in der Praxis
und das wird sich nicht schnell
verändern das könnte man sagen aber das
wird nicht schnell sein und Sie haben ja
auch gar nicht das
könnten denn die Ärzte oder die der
Arbeiten selber ändern
schlecht organisiert in den
Organisationen also ich meine wir sind
alle digital letztendlich wir
wünschen uns Digitalisierung die uns
weiterbringen wir haben jetzt eine
Telematik-Infrastruktur die uns
überhaupt gar keine Vorteile bringt
sondern nur Nachteile auch das ist etwas
was man abbauen muss insofern muss man
einfach sehen dass das diese Leistung
die jetzt ambulant gemacht werden sollen
tatsächlich dann auch machbar sind im
Moment haben wir eine überlastete
Ambulanz die aber gegen die Wand
gefahren wird die Praxen werden zu
machen die Situation werden sich
verschärfen es gibt keine
endbudgetierung der Leistung ja auch das
ist im Koalitionsvertrag beschlossen
worden wir arbeiten hier in Berlin z.B
immer noch für 82%, also wir kriegen 82%
unsere Leistung im Moment bezahlt das
heißt können Sie heute Abend zum Pizza
essen gehen und zehn Euro für eine Pizza
bestellen und dann aber nur acht Euro 20
ausgeben wollen dann wird in der
Pizzabäcker ganz schön eins um die Ohren
geben und so ist aber die Situation der
Kinder und jugendärzte ambulant in
Berlin und da macht Herr Lauterbach
leider gar nichts er steckt viel Geld in
unseren Augen unsinnige Maßnahmen in die
Klinik Unsinn was finden sie denn
konkret unsinnig ist sozusagen
erwachsenenärzte auf Kinderstationen
arbeiten zu lassen
Erwachsenen Pflegepersonal auf
Kinderstationen arbeiten zu lassen das
ist etwas was fernab ist von jeder Logik
die Frage ist es war glaube ich so
gedacht wenn dann bevor niemand da ist
ist es besser eine erwachsenenpfleger
akzeptieren dass wir eine schlechte
Kinder und Jugendmedizin machen und
damit auch die Gesundheit gefährden das
muss man dann auch klar und deutlich
sagen so dramatisch wie sie schildern
wir sind das Land mit 13,1
Motor Bruttoinlandsprodukt was deutlich
am meisten für Gesundheit ausgibt also
wir müssen uns auch klar sein deswegen
ist der Ruf immer mehr Geld mehr Geld
mehr Geld aber doch trotzdem
weil wir die Leute ins Bett legen das
ist teuer stationäre Versorgung statt
die ambulant zu zu versorgen wir sind
in effizient wir haben ja Personal wir
brauchen wir brauchen nur besonders viel
Personal weil wir so viele stationäre
Patienten haben natürlich sind wir Ihnen
effizient und da geht das Geld drauf
deswegen greift die Kommission macht
keine Versprechung das ist mehr Geld
gibt sondern sagt wir müssen die an die
Strukturen dran wir müssen das ist
natürlich böse wir müssen da effizienter
werden wir müssen uns neu sortieren es
sind darf weder nur das machen was was
er kann und nur bei Patienten muss wo es
eben auch indiziert ist und werde wäre
es ambulant gemacht werden kann die die
die Operation oder sowas ambulant
gemacht wir sprechen im Moment von
Kindern ja
sechs Monate alt sind Sauerstoffbedarf
haben und sie sagen die kann brauche ich
nicht in der stationären Überwachung
unterzubringen also das finde ich schon
eine ganz schöne
Fahrt muss ich sagen Frau baradari
ja ich muss tatsächlich hier an dieser
Stelle auch als Berichterstatterin
brechen ich denke viele leider auch
Experten haben die Erwachsenen im Kopf
aber die Pädiatrie ist wirklich ganz
besonders zu betrachten ein Beispiel
Kinderklinik Siegen ca 40 km von hier
hier entfernt 19 Kinder sind an einem
Tag entlassen worden um 14 Uhr waren
schon 15 Plätze in der Kinderklinik
vergeben also da kann man wirklich nicht
von Ineffizienz sprechen und
normalerweise sind 1% der Kinder
intensivpflicht im Moment sind es zehn
Prozent es ist klar dass wir hier eine
besondere Situation haben aber was
Pädiatrie angeht brauchen wir einen ganz
besonderen Bestandsschutz und die darf
nicht halt eben so verglichen werden mit
Erwachsenen Kliniken und das heißt
man kann eine Entschuldigung
man kann eine Reform und im
Krankenhausbereich nicht machen wenn man
nicht daneben tatsächlich auch eine
Reform im ambulanten Bereich macht das
wird nicht gut gehen okay also das noch
ein wichtiger Punkt das ist ja das was
hier auch sagen vor Klapper ist das ist
da fehlt da was wenn wir jetzt nur auf
die Krankenhäuser schaut
ich glaube man muss es auch so ein
bisschen Schritt für Schritt machen also
Herr Lauterbach hat letztens beim
Treffen mit Journalisten einen Zettel
ausgeteilt mit all sein Vorhaben und es
sind im Moment acht Gesetze und 48
Verordnungen die er im Laufe dieses
Jahres entweder schon auf dem Weg
gebracht hat oder gerade auf dem Weg
bringt ich habe den Eindruck er versucht
gerade eins zu vermitteln dass er mehr
kann als Corona und deswegen gerade auf
ganz vielen Baustellen gleichzeitig
funktioniert ich glaube man darf sich
keine Illusion machen dass diese Reform
die heute vorgeschlagen wurde dauern
wird also derzeit Horizont das waren ja
die fünf Jahre wurden heute genannt bis
es dann tatsächlich so weit sein soll
also darf man sich glaube ich nicht zu
viel versprechen was ich auch ähm etwas
irritierend fand ist das ähm Herr
Lauterbach gesagt hat
die Meinung der der Verbände also der
Vertreter der Krankenkassen der
Krankenhäuser die sind ja sehr wichtige
Akteure die das ja auch alles umsetzen
müssen würde keine Rolle spielen also
die
die Reformen Vorschläge wurden ja von
einer wissenschaftlichen Kommission
erarbeitet was sie auch erstmal eine
charmante Idee ist dass man sagt man
lässt alle anderen
lobbyvertreter raus macht das erstmal
wissenschaftlich aber dann würde ich
erwarten dass man sagt so ihr seid jetzt
alle herzlich eingeladen gemeinsam
montags oder drei stündigen Sitzung ins
Minister also sage ich kann nämlich sein
werde ich weiß dass diese drei Stunden
die Anhörung stattfindet hat gesagt das
wird eh keine Rolle spielen was sie
sagen immer der hört sie es an aber er
wird es nicht umsetzen aber nicht ganz
so geschickt
aber jetzt noch mal wie nimmt man die
Leute mit die es umsetzen müssen das ist
ja wichtig
naja wir müssen wir müssen dafür da
dafür bewerben und es gibt ja auch sehr
sehr viele die die Probleme erkennen es
sind sich nicht alle schon direkt einig
über die Rezepte aber das etwas
passieren muss ist den ist ja der
allermeisten klar und die üblichen
Rezepte wir brauchen mehr Personal ist
wirklich schwierig angesichts der
demografischen transition die jetzt
wirklich heißt Leute wie ich gehe
demnächst in Ruhestand 1,3 Millionen pro
Jahr und es Rücken nur 800.000 nach das
ist ganz schwierig und mehr Geld als als
zweite oder erste Antwort von vielen ist
auch schwierig also wir müssen weniger
Bürokratie müssen auch immer wir müssen
realisieren
ohne deutlich mehr Geld und ohne
deutlich mehr Personal und wenn dann das
Wort Revolution fällt mehr noch als
Reform wäre denn dann nicht die
letztendlich große Revolution und wäre
das zu erwarten dass es dann keine
Trennung mehr gibt zwischen privaten und
gesetzlichen Versicherten
wäre das hilfreich
das kann ich so nicht beantworten aber
ich würde gerne mal die Frage stellen
wer in ihrer Kommission denn ambulant
tätig ist oder ambulante Wissenschaft
macht wer in dieser Kommission macht das
sie entscheiden überall ambulante
Medizin wer von ihnen hat Ahnung von
Ambulanz von ambulanter Medizin
ja sehr in der ersten ist es eine
krankenhauskommission zweitens würde ich
sagen jemand der eine Notaufnahme leitet
der hat der sieht die Patienten auch
aber ambulant also und die die anderen
die nicht Mediziner also die die
Juristen z.B die sind vom Krankenhaus
sozusagen in diesen genauso nah am
Krankenhaus wie eine ambulanten Medizin
ja am Ende dieser Sendung Maske das tut
mir leid
genau das ist das Problem er wird über
ambulante Medizin sozusagen entschieden
und es gibt keinen Menschen der darüber
um die Krankenhäuser ambulantisierung
von Krankenhäusern okay gut also für die
nächste Sendung die wir über
Gesundheitspolitik machen Frau Maske
vorbereitet und der musste vielen Dank
fürs diskutieren ihnen vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen und ich möchte sie noch darauf
hinweisen dass sie morgen schon eine
spezielle Phönix Runde sehen dann haben
wir nämlich mal doppelt so viel Zeit 90
Minuten dann können wir solche Fragen
auch länger erörtern 5 Gäste ein Abend
über Deutschland ein ganzer Abend in dem
wir fragen wie es ihnen eigentlich geht
in diesem Winter mit all den Krisen und
Konflikten die wir dauernd zu bewältigen
haben 20 Uhr sind wir schon für Sie da
morgen ein Abend über Deutschland ich
freue mich auf Sie bis dann
[Musik]